préféré que malgré tout le glyphosate
est très présent partout dans le monde
où il ya des parce qu'il est
redoutablement efficace selon ce que
nous disent les agriculteurs mais
d'abord c'est quoi le glyphosate c'est
quoi le round up et donc c'est qu'on
prend là la molécule du glyphosate on va
mettre du solvant dessus et ça vous
permet de vous débarrasser des fameuses
mauvaises herbes qui poussent par
exemple dans votre entrée de garage
alors ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on va
pulvériser la mauvaise herbe ce que ça
fait c'est que ça va bloquer la
photosynthèse de la plante dont il ya
plus de lumière qui arrive est la plante
n'arrive plus à produire du tissu
végétal est donc tout simplement elle va
mourir alors c'est une formule assez
sain qui était brevetée par monsanto en
1974 et pour les agriculteurs baisse est
un peu du pain bénit parce que ça permet
de préparer la la terre avant de semer
donc on va pulvériser évidemment avec le
tracteur est donc la terre est prête à
être utilisée mais ce qui a changé
complètement la donne à z
sega temps plus tard on est passé des
semences de maïs par exemple à des
semences de maïs génétiquement modifiés
crée évidemment par moins de santo et ça
permet une fois qu'on a planté qu'on a
semé le maïs mon il sort de terre et on
peut malgré tout pulvériser avec le
roundup parce qu'il est devenu résistant
mais ça tu l'ensemble des mauvaises
herbes donc évidemment pour les fermiers
c'est tout profit parce qu'on vient
évidemment beaucoup de temps ce qui fait
que ce fameux glyphosate et bien entre
74 et 2014
ça a été multiplié par 100 l'utilisation
du fameux glyphosate et un chiffre qui
est assez incroyable c'est que jusqu'en
2014 à peu près chaque année on utilise
entre 8 126 mille tonnes de glyphosate à
travers le monde c'est évidemment énorme
comme quantité mais il reste que pour le
fermier mais d'abord les rendements sont
meilleurs il ya moins de mauvaises
herbes donc plus de plantes et puis
surtout on gagne du temps et le temps
évidemment c'est de l'argent puis donc
c'est très très populaire il ya quand
même quelques pays qui on a essayé de
l'interdire oui le tout premier pays en
fait il s'agit du salvador qui l'a
interdite en 2013 mais il est revenu en
arrière donc finalement on continue
d'utiliser le glyphosate après ça il ya
eu le sri lanka en 2015 et là jusque
l'année dernière on a décidé de modifier
d'assouplir la réglementation pour
permettre notamment aux producteurs
d'hévéa donc le larbre caoutchouc et
encore les feuilles de thé de pouvoir
utiliser de glyphosate alors aujourd'hui
bayal vietnam qui vient d'adopter en
une nouvelle loi qui bannit complètement
même chose pour l'autriche quelques
semaines plus tard
et on s'attend à ce que l'allemagne le
fasse en 2023 il reste donc ce sont à
peu près les trois seuls pays qui vont
bannir ou qui l'ont banni et ça reste
seulement pour les mêmes pour les usages
professionnels donc les fermiers mais
ailleurs dans le monde il ya des
municipalités qui ont adopté des
règlements mais ça concerne juste
utilisation pour le jardinier mais dans
les champs ça continue d'être utilisée
merci beaucoup frédéric